All right, so let's look at the first one. We have our sample mean, x bar minus
the z score times the standard deviation meaning we have this number of standard
deviations less than the mean. And that's what we did with z here being 1.96,
since this is 95%. And then over here on the other side, we have our sample mean
plus z amounts of standard deviations or standard errors. So this is what we did
to find the confidence interval. However we did not subtract Z standard
deviations from the population mean. Remember the original population mean was
point zero seven, seven, If we did that then we would get a confidence interval
for the original population mean. And that's not what we're interested in. This
third one, we have our sample mean, minus and instead of Z we have the actual Z
value, 1.96 times the standard error. So we have 1.96 standard errors less than
this sample mean. So that is what we get. And same with over here we have 1.96
standard error plus the sample mean. And this one doesn't really make sense
because we can't just subtract the number of standard deviations, we need to
multiply this number of standard deviations by what the standard deviation
actually is. To find the distance away from the sample mean we need to go.
Hopefully that makes sense. Great job.